[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAK LAKSHMANAN: So what I'm
going to be talking about
is how to train image and text
models, classification models,
faster with TPUs,
Tensor Processing Units,
on Google Cloud, primarily
using ML Engine, which
is our managed infra platform.
But I'll also show you how you
can directly connect to a TPU
from your Jupyter notebook.
And you can run things
directly from there as well.
So what exactly are TPUs?
So TPUs are essentially
hardware accelerators.
Mostly, I think, all my career
I've dealt with software.
But hardware is this kind of
cool thing that's out there.
And it's been fun basically
getting to work with TPUs.
The key thing about TPUs is that
unlike most processors that we
are all familiar with, this is
not general purpose software.
Right.
When you think of CPUs,
you think of GPUs.
These are general purpose.
You can basically do
graphics on a GPU.
You can do rendering on a GPU.
You can do now gaming.
You can do bitcoin mining.
You can do a variety
of things on a GPU.
There's only one thing you can
do on a TPU, machine learning.
So it's an ASIC.
It's an Application
Specific Chip that's
meant for one specific task.
But what that brings you is
that it is the fastest hardware
out there for machine learning.
So there is this
benchmark thing that's
run by Stanford called
the DAWN benchmark.
And basically the TPU reached--
they have a desired
accuracy of 93% an image.
And how long does it
take to get to that?
And it basically reaches
that in less than 30 minutes.
So what I'll basically
talk about here
is I'll talk about image
and text models, the two
major kinds of models
that people train,
and how you could do this on
your own data using our TPUs.
So I'd also finally talk
about this final thing
about if you wrote
a custom model,
how would you adapt it so
that you could run on a TPU.
So I'll talk about
why we're doing TPUs,
how to develop
with them, and then
talk about state of
the art image models,
state of the art text models.
And as Puneith
said in the intro,
I really get excited
when people can do this
without writing any
code, or writing
minimal amounts of code.
So the two parts about the
state of the art models
are about how can
you take something
that is bleeding edge, and
basically just go use it.
And finally, I'll talk
about custom models.
And the custom models are for
the geeks, who basically say,
no.
I want to write my own.
I want to actually do it myself.
And we'll talk
about that as well.
So, first of all, why TPUs?
Why would we go around and
develop a custom ASIC chip?
And we have three
generations of it already.
Right?
At least.
We're not a ship company.
Right.
Why is it that we care?
And it basically comes
down to a few things
that are interesting from the
AI development point of view.
The first is, this
is a graph that
basically shows how the size of
your data affects error rate.
And this is common to a
variety of different problems.
This particular graph
shows natural language.
But whether you take images,
you take time series,
you take text, the graph
looks very similar.
The numbers are different,
but the graph shape
looks very similar.
So what is this?
This is the error rate.
And the error rate drops as
the size of your data goes up.
All right.
Fine.
But let's look at the drop.
It's linear.
Right.
The error rate is
dropping linearly.
But what's happened to the data?
What's the x-axis here?
Exactly.
Exponential.
Right.
Between this grid line
and this grid line,
what's happening to your data?
Doubling.
Right.
So for every small
decrease in error rate--
when we say we need a lot
of data for deep learning,
what are we talking about?
We're talking about twice,
four times, eight times,
32 times as much data.
We're not talking
about 10% more data.
We're talking oodles more data.
So that's the first graph.
The second graph
here is year on year.
So AlexNet, which
basically jumpstarted
the whole deep learning
idea with eight layers.
Now, know much
compute did they need?
That's some level of compute.
And neural architecture search,
that is Google's Auto ML.
So that's basically
going ahead and searching
for appropriate models using
reinforcement learning.
So that's the amount
of compute it needs.
And then Alpha Go, which
is even higher than that.
So, again, this is every year.
And this is the amount of
compute that is needed.
And what's happening
to the compute?
It's going 10 times.
Right.
So pretty much year on year.
So if you then put these
two graphs together,
it turns out that we now
need about 300,000 times more
compute than we needed
just a few years ago.
OK.
So that is the big thing
that's staring us in the face.
We need huge amounts
of compute to be
able to get to better
and better accuracy.
And better accuracy
is hugely important.
Right.
The reason we all
speak into our phones
now is because the
accuracy dropped
below a certain threshold.
Until it dropped
below that threshold,
it wasn't good enough.
We couldn't actually
embed it into products.
And now we can.
And so it's hugely important
that we train these models.
And we train them on our
data, with our jargon,
with our industry
jargon, et cetera.
So this is Jeff Dean who is
like the lead of AI at Google.
So in 2014 he did the back
of the envelope calculation
and said, if everybody speaks
into their phone for three
minutes, we'll exhaust all
available computing resources
on the planet.
So what do you do?
You develop a TPU.
Right.
So basically the
other thing to do
is when will
Moore's Law save us?
Year on year, of course,
computing power keeps going up.
And these are all the
different revolutions
that will happen in computing
with the number of cores,
the different power, and so on.
And long story
short, it turns out
that pretty much everything has
started plateauing around 2010.
So Moore's Law is
not going to save us.
We need a lot more compute.
But Moore's Law isn't
going to save us.
Right.
So that's basically
why it now is--
forget about general
purpose processors.
If you have a need for something
that has to be developed,
then you go develop it
if it's often enough.
So in 2015, a year
after Jeff Dean's back
of the envelope calculation, we
came up with TPU version one.
And remember what
his calculation was.
It was basically
around if everyone
speaks into their phone.
So what was he worried about?
Was he worried about
training, or was he
worried about inference?
Inference.
So TPU version one
was about inference.
It was about
basically making sure
that our models
that were trained
could basically handle the
load of all of our users
basically using it.
Right.
So prediction.
The training can take care
of itself, we thought.
Let's get the inference out.
So that was TPU version one.
Version two onwards, it does
both training and inference.
And then version three,
currently in alpha.
Right.
All of these that
we've developed,
one of the things
about an ASIC chip
is now you've got to put
in a lot of investment
to develop it.
So there is a lot of incentive
for us to basically open it up
for other people to
use, and the way Google
opens up for enterprise users
is through Google Cloud.
So what is a TPU?
This is basically the schematic
of what a TPU looks like.
So you basically have
two cores per chip.
And each core basically contains
a matrix multiplication unit.
That's the heart of it.
It also contains scalar
and vector units.
I'll talk about those.
And it contains about
8 GBs of memory.
I'm talking about
TPU version two.
Version three has more memory.
It has 32 GBs.
But version two
has 8 GBs of memory
per core, which, in the larger
scheme of things, seems tiny.
Right.
Why would you build a chip
with just 8 GBs of memory?
But it turns out that it's
not about this one core.
It's about basically how
many you can put together.
So per chip, you
basically have, now,
per core you basically
have all of these things.
And you have about
8 GB memory cores.
Four of these chips per TPU.
Each chip contains two cores.
So you have a total
of eight cores on one
of these TPU boards.
But then you take
these TPU boards,
and you put them
together into a rack.
Right.
And that's what we call a pod.
And a pod has 64 TPUs.
And each of those TPUs has
four chips, has two cores.
So that's basically getting
the power out there.
So great.
So you have 64 TPUs per pod.
And the matrix multiplication
is where all of the power
comes in.
The idea is that you go
look at machine learning.
And what is all of
machine learning?
It's essentially linear
algebra, matrix multiplication.
So you build a system that does
matrix multiplication very fast
and nothing else.
And that's basically
the idea behind a TPU.
Just do matrix multiplication
really, really, really fast.
So the idea is to basically
pack a lot of power and density,
because it doesn't have
to do anything else.
All it does is matrix
multiplication.
And if we can do that, the
idea is it's a fixed function
architecture.
And if you were
to think of a CPU
as doing scalar math, a
GPU of doing vector math,
a TPU is doing Tensor math.
Right.
And it's just focusing
on matrices and matrix
multiplication.
The second part of this is
that all of those chips,
they aren't individual.
They're all connected by a
very high speed toroidal mesh.
And what this essentially
means is that they
can function as one unit.
So you're not actually
treating one core.
Actually you're treating
all of them together.
So that's great.
But what that actually means
is that as you increase
the number of cores, the
number of images that you're
processing, or the number of
texts that you're processing
grows linearly.
This is a very, very,
very hard graph to get.
We're all familiar with it.
Right?
You distribute your code.
What happens to your code?
It doesn't scale linearly.
Right.
It slows down.
You're the fastest
if you use just one.
With the TPU the idea
that one is a pod.
As long as you're within
the pod, it's just as fast.
So you're basically getting
that high speed interconnect
so that you're getting
the scaling that is pretty
linear for the number of cores.
AUDIENCE: You're not concerned
about the clock speed, as well
as the feature size?
LAK LAKSHMANAN: Yeah.
So all of those things
we are concerned about.
And those are optimized.
But every chip is optimizing it.
The key idea here
is we're focused
on matrix multiplication.
And we'll make sure
that this thing will
be focused on the networking
so that this thing scales
linearly.
I think it's a
Google philosophy.
Right?
Where don't do it
on one machine.
Do it on multiple machines.
Scale them out.
And you get scale
through numbers.
It is that same philosophy
of the whole map.
Reduce ideas on all of
those, applied to compute.
AUDIENCE: So in your
ASIC, what features
size [INAUDIBLE] built on?
And what's the clock
speed you're using?
LAK LAKSHMANAN: I have no
idea what the clock speed is.
I'm a software guy.
[LAUGHS]
I'm very concerned with what
I can get out of the TPUs.
I can find out.
I don't know even
if we release them.
If we do, I can
find out for you.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What's the maximum
pods you get, and [INAUDIBLE]??
LAK LAKSHMANAN: Oh, the maximum?
There's 64 TPUs in a pod.
OK.
You can go up to 64.
You can also get multiple pods.
But at that point, the
linearity starts to break down.
Right.
As long as you're within
a pod, you're basically
getting this amazing network.
Once you have a second pod,
it's not as much anymore.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAK LAKSHMANAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It is
critical, depending
on the feature size [INAUDIBLE]
the number of code you use.
That defines the power and how
you will be able to pack in.
LAK LAKSHMANAN: Right.
AUDIENCE: So it's a
very critical parameter.
LAK LAKSHMANAN: OK.
OK.
Cool.
So we have a TPU.
So this is why we
developed the TPU.
How do you develop with the TPU?
Right.
So that's basically now,
onto the software side.
So first thing is, we
are developing the TPU.
It's kind of helpful
to have a TPU that's
just attached to your computer.
How do you attach a
TPU to your computer?
It's sitting there
in Google Cloud.
So what you do is
that you basically
spin up a virtual
machine in Google Cloud.
And that virtual machine is
connected behind the Google
firewall to a TPU.
So you're basically going
to have your cloud TPU,
and you're connecting to it.
And essentially what you do is
you get a CTPU or a cloud TPU
up.
So if you're in Cloud
Shell or you can actually
download the CTPU program,
and you can install it,
you can basically do CTPU up,
give it the name of the TPU.
And then, from
your local machine,
you basically do SSH into the
cloud TPU with a port forward.
Basically I'm port forwarding
port 8888 to my local machine.
When then I start
Jupyter with port 8888
I'm actually
connected to the TPU.
Right.
So anything that I run
in that Jupyter notebook
is going to be
running on the TPU.
That is basically the idea.
Or I can run
something on the TPU.
So how does that work?
So what I did was just before we
started the class, or the talk,
I went ahead and
basically did the CTPU up.
And I started Jupyter.
So let me just go ahead
and do Jupyter here.
And at this point, I'm
doing local host 8888.
And I now have a
Jupyter notebook.
And let me go ahead
and start a terminal.
And what I'll do
inside the terminal
is that I will do a
Git clone of my repo.
Google Cloud Platform.
Training data analyst.
All right.
So it's been Git cloned.
And I can go back here.
And the repo showed up.
And let me go ahead and
pull up its notebook.
TPU.
So this is all on GitHub.
So TPU fundamentals.
So now I have a notebook.
So this notebook
now, when I run it,
it's running on this
CPU, or this VM that's
attached to the CPU.
So most of this stuff
is happening on the VM.
But if I say, run this
function on the TPU,
it'll run that
function on the TPU.
So first thing that I'm doing
is that the name of my TPU
was LakTPU.
So I'll do this.
And it was in US central C.
So if I do that--
what happened?
Demo gods.
OK.
This thing is still running.
Why is still?
Reload it.
OK.
There.
Much better.
OK.
So let's run that.
Oh.
I need to change this.
It says there is no such TPU.
So if I run that
again, so there it is.
So the first thing
I did was that I
said, go ahead and find a
TPU with this name that's
attached to this machine.
So it now found that TPU.
So at this point, I have a TPU.
So let's go ahead and say that
we have a function, a very,
very fancy function.
I just want to add x and y.
So I have a function.
I have that function.
And normally I would
just add x and y.
But what I'm going to
do here is that I'm
going to say, go ahead and
call the add function, passing
in x and y, and run that
function on the TPU.
So as long as you
have a Python function
all that you have to do is
basically say, TPU rewrite.
Here's my function.
These are the
arguments it takes.
Run it for me.
And that function is
going to run on the TPU.
So that's essentially
what programming
a TPU looks like is basically
writing some function that
is basically going to get done.
So that is a TPU add.
And if you know how
TensorFlow works,
that has created the graph.
And if you want to run
it, I initialize the TPU.
And then I say, please go
ahead and run the TPU add.
And we should get the
result of adding x and y.
Right.
The x is basically
numbers from 0 to 15.
And I'm adding ones to it.
So I get numbers from 1 to
17, 1 to 16. x is 0 to 15.
So I get 1 to 16.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: This should also run
in the Eagle mode [INAUDIBLE],,
right?
LAK LAKSHMANAN: This will
also run in the Eagle mode.
Correct.
You can also do
Eagle mode right now.
But the Eagle mode
makes it harder,
because I want to
do a TPU rewrite.
So it makes it much easier
if you're doing it with this,
create a graph.
Rewrite the graph.
And then run the graph.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Should it be Tensor?
The parameters should be Tensor?
LAK LAKSHMANAN: The
parameters have to be Tensors.
Correct.
They have to be Tensors.
And I'll also talk about,
ideally these Tensors are huge.
And they basically have batch
sizes of like 128 or so.
Because, again, it's
this fixed function that
is the optimal behavior on it.
So as long as you have
that, that's essentially it.
Now we can, of course,
take this and put
it together into something
a bit more interesting.
So what I'm doing
here is that I want
to basically get the MNIST
data, our Hello World,
and then basically create
two NumPy arrays of that.
So that's basically what
I'm doing in this step.
And now I'm
downloading the data.
And having gotten it, I
have x train and y test.
And I then have a function to
do my fit, my fit and my train
function.
So what I'm doing is I'm
taking the image that I get in,
and basically flattening it out.
I have a 28x28 image in MNIST,
making that a 784 array.
And then here take my
weights, which is a variable,
taking my bias, which
is another variable,
and then doing a very fancy
logistic regression model.
So x times w plus b.
Right.
That's my model.
And then my loss.
So this is the one change
that you have to make.
So my loss is normally
by cross entropy.
And my optimizer basically
optimizes the loss.
I can use an atom optimizer.
But you don't use the
atom optimizer directly.
What you do is that you
take that atom optimizer,
and you wrap it up in what is
called a cross shard optimizer.
Remember what I said about a
TPU basically scales linearly
with the number of cores?
The cross shard optimizer
is what does that.
Right.
So instead of it optimizing
on that one core,
it's going to take this batch of
images that's going to come in.
It's going to spread them
out onto how many ever
cores you have.
And each of the cores is
going to do this optimization
on its part of the batch.
And then there is a barrier.
And everything hits the barrier.
All of the gradients
get averaged.
And then you're on
to the next step.
So the cross shard optimizer
is the one change you typically
have to make to your code
to basically take advantage
of this linear scaling.
So we do this, and
then we say, OK, I want
to go ahead and optimize it.
So at this point then,
we can basically say,
I want to take my fifth batch
function and rewrite it.
TPU rewrite of the
fifth batch function.
So my original function
would run on a CPU or a GPU.
Rewrite it so that it
can also run on a TPU.
And run it for one step.
Actually run for 50 steps.
Range of 50.
OK.
And then you basically
get your losses.
So that's pretty much it.
So you can do
iterative development
with a TPU attached
to your machine.
And you're writing
a Jupyter notebook.
The way you're familiar with
running things, with a GPU,
it's very similar, except that
you would now have the ability
to scale this thing out
to really fast hardware,
and really fast processing.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Which of the
optimizers beside Atom
is supported?
LAK LAKSHMANAN: Which optimizers
besides Atom are supported?
Almost all of them.
Right.
There may be some--
and you can also take
your own optimizers,
and you can wrap them up.
But we're getting
to this point where
almost all of them in
TensorFlow are supported.
There is some list of ops
that are not supported.
But as a first approximation,
assume that it is.
And if it's not, like holler.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Will this
interface change much when
you shift to TensorFlow 2?
LAK LAKSHMANAN: Will
this interface shift?
This is TF.contrib.TPU.
So yes.
It is going to change.
Yes.
But basically, the way it
works is everything starts
with contrib.
We get the APIs and
everything correct.
And then we fold it in.
This particular API is not
going to change much I think.
It's just a one
function rewrite.
But later on when I
talk to you about how
to do an estimator, which
is this higher level thing,
that is going to
change significantly.
The idea being that
out of the box,
we want our estimators to
actually work on a TPU,
without you having
to change your code.
Today because TPUs are new
and the hardware is coming up,
so there is this process by
which you write your estimator
code and you have to modify it.
You have to add in the
cross shard optimizer,
those kinds of things.
But we want to get to the point
where it's just automatic.
You run on a TPU.
And this graph modification
just happens on that device
before it happened.
Right.
So that's our end goal.
We want to get there.
But right now,
until we get there,
these are the few
changes we make.
But what I'm hoping to
say is that it's not
this magical thing.
These changes are very minor.
You're essentially using
cross shard optimizer.
And you're taking this
function that you want to write
and saying call it
with a TPU rewrite.
And that's it.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can you
use TPUs with Keras?
LAK LAKSHMANAN: Can we
Yes.
Right.
Absolutely.
Yes.
You can use TPUs with Keras.
And your model function can
be any TensorFlow function,
including a Keras function.
But you don't use your
inputs and outputs.
I'll talk about those.
Remember that the TPU
does only one thing,
and does one thing
well, which is the math.
So you want to make
sure that that math can
be written in Keras.
Keras and TensorFlow, it works.
AUDIENCE: Do you need to
convert the Keras [INAUDIBLE]..
LAK LAKSHMANAN: You don't
have to convert your Keras
models to TF layers.
No.
It just works.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
LAK LAKSHMANAN: No.
Not currently.
Yes.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What about
with Eager Execution?
LAK LAKSHMANAN: What
about Eager Execution?
So that's one of the things
that's on the roadmap.
It's something that we
want to be able to support.
But right now there is
this rewriting phase.
So it doesn't quite
work with that.
But the idea being that
you develop with Eager,
and then basically in production
time you run it on a TPU
is probably the more acceptable
way to think about it.
And that's your training.
And then, again, we
have a predict function.
And that's just a
traditional function.
And you want to run it on a
TPU, and do TPU rewrite of that.
So, again, same thing.
So having done that, that will
basically do the prediction.
And you can plot
your predictions.
Oh, I didn't install Matplotlib.
Nevermind.
OK.
So that was the demo.
Right.
And that's the link to the
notebook that I was running.
OK.
So essentially
follow those steps,
and basically run the notebook.
And you can run it on Jupyter.
So all of my demos, everything
is on GitHub already.
So you should be
able to try them out.
OK.
So that was cool.
So I showed you how to
develop on a TPU from scratch.
You basically have some
TensorFlow function,
some thing, and you
just want to run it.
But let's next step a
little bit higher now.
Let's say I want to do a
state of the art image model.
Right.
Well, we could write it.
But why are we writing it?
Resonant 50 is around.
Can we just take a
Resonant 50 and run it?
And so there is a variety
of reference models
available for a cloud TPU.
So if you're thinking
of image recognition,
you basically have your
Resonant 50 101, 200, et cetera.
There's a variety of different
Resonant models available.
AmoebaNet is actually a
pretty interesting choice.
What AmoebaNet is is a
neural architecture search
done on the ImageNet, with
the constraint that it should
train very fast on a TPU.
Right.
So it is fast.
It is accurate.
And it's trained on
a very large dataset.
So AmoebaNet is a pretty
good choice if you're saying,
I want to do image recognition.
But Resonant is the one that
more people are familiar with.
So I'll just show you Resonant.
They all work very similarly.
So if you're interested
in object detection,
RetinaNet, if you're
interested in running things
on a phone, MobileNet
or machine translation,
I'll talk about the
transformer model.
All of these are
transformer based.
And at that time I'll show
you an example of training
something on your own problem.
And those speech recognition,
image generation,
there are more of
these reference models
that are coming up all the time.
They're all in this GitHub repo.
So if you want to go ahead and
do a state of the art model,
it's all there.
So let's look at how to take
one of those state of the art
models, and just run
them on your own data.
So the one I'm going to
pick is the Resonant 50.
So let's say I want to
train the Resonant 50.
And that's the
one that basically
was at the top of
the DAWN Benchmark.
And it's in the repo that I just
talked about, TensorFlow/TPU.
And there's a model's
official Resonant.
So that's the model to run it.
So first thing that you
do, how do you run it?
What I just showed
you was basically
starting a TPU on
a Compute Engine.
That is useful for
development purposes.
You want a TPU attached
to your desktop machine
so you can basically run
things while you're developing.
But now I want to train
Resonant 50 on my large data.
That's no longer development.
That is now production.
And for productionization,
you want something
that is fully managed.
The idea being,
you submit a job.
And ML Engine starts up a
TPU, trains the whole thing,
shuts the TPU down.
Right.
So it bandages the
entire lifecycle,
without you having to
start and stop it yourself.
So all that you
have to do is when
you launch the job you
basically scale this.
So a scaled tier is a basic TPU.
So basically specify
the base tier.
You can also do
Kubernetes if you
are basically interested in
having full control over it.
So you can have a Kubernetes
thing with Kubeflow.
And you can have TPUs as part
of your Kubernetes flock.
I won't talk about that.
So demo number two.
So I want to basically
train or deploy Resonant
on my own data using ML Engine.
So the links here basically
take me to a code lab.
How many of you are
familiar with code labs?
So a set of instructions
that you basically
follow that essentially
tell you how to do it.
So the first thing is
to basically set up
our environment.
So this is basically telling
me to do a Cloud Shell.
And then convert.
So our first step is to
convert all of our JPEG data.
So I will have data that
I will want to convert.
So let's see.
OK.
The data looks like this.
So I'm going to be training
on a data set of flowers.
And I want to train
it to basically say,
these are the flower
categories in these images.
The images all look like this.
And the CSV file that I'm
training on looks like this.
OK.
Everybody can see, right?
So it's essentially
the name of the file,
or the location of the
file or cloud storage,
and the category.
OK.
So you basically have a bunch
of images, each of which
has-- this is the file,
and this is the category.
So you have that as a CSV file.
You have a similar
file for evaluation.
So you have two files, one for
training, one for evaluation.
And that's all you need.
OK.
From this point onwards, it's
just follow these instructions.
Train your model.
So our first step is
to go open Cloud Shell
and make sure that
these things exist.
So I can go down here.
I can go to Cloud Shell.
And do that.
And make sure that
the input exists.
And the next thing is to find
the dictionary of labels.
And what I am doing here
is that I'm basically
kind of taking those
files and doing a sort,
and finding the unique
of all of the labels
to basically make
sure that I have
the canonical list of labels.
So do that.
And so there.
Those are the five types
of flowers in my dataset.
So that is now my dictionary.
And at this point, I'm ready
to basically train on the TPU.
Now, can I provide my JPEG files
and my CSV files to my trainer?
If I were doing it on a GPU,
that's exactly what I would do.
Right.
I would write an input function.
It would read the JPEG.
It would train it.
And I would be done.
But when you're
training on a TPU,
there's something to
be very careful about,
which is that the TPU is
extremely, extremely fast.
And it's good. at
only one thing.
What is it good at?
AUDIENCE: Matrix multiplication.
LAK LAKSHMANAN:
Matrix multiplication.
Is it good at reading JPEGs?
No.
So what do we have to do?
We're going to do
a pre processing.
We're going to take
our JPEG files,
our CSV files, take
all the things,
and basically put
them into TF records.
So instead of it reading one
file for every input, then
a batch--
if it has to process a batch,
it has to read all these files,
and is going to be really slow.
Right.
The TPU is going
to be sitting there
waiting for our input pipeline
to finish reading the data.
So instead what
we're going to do
is that we're going to
take all those files,
and basically dump them
into a single TF record file
so that we can read in a
huge batch all at once.
And that way we limit the IO
overhead that is being paid.
Does this make sense?
So first step, let's
convert it into TF records.
So to convert those
into TF records
there is, in the
TPU repo itself--
So TensorFlow, GitHub.
TensorFlow, TPU.
So in there, in the
tools, in the data sets,
it's a nice little program
called JPEG to TF Record.
So we're just going to run that.
OK.
So it's going to
basically go ahead
and take all of our JPEG
files and convert them
into TF records.
So this is an
Apache Beam program.
How many of you have
heard of Apache Beam?
Beam.
OK.
Beam is this distributed
execution environment.
So you basically write
your code in Python.
And you can run it in a
variety of different runners,
including Flink,
and including Spark.
But also including
Cloud Dataflow and GCP.
So what I'm going to do
in the next step of this
is that I'm going to basically
take my code and run it.
OK.
Run this pre-processing code.
And at this point, it's
going to shoot this code off
to the cloud.
It's going to get
distributed onto a bunch
of different machines.
It's going to process
all of these files
and create TensorFlow records.
And then we can train off
the TensorFlow records.
This is going to take a
little while, because it
has to process all this data.
So I'm going to do
the Julia Child thing.
I'm going to say, oh,
I put that in the oven.
Here it is.
It's already done.
Right.
So I already have in my
cloud storage bucket--
I hope I have in my cloud
storage bucket, Training Demos
ML.
The pre-processed data
is already present.
So there it is.
So flowers, flowers,
flowers, flowers.
Yeah.
There it is.
Flowers.
And in there is my
pre-processed data somewhere.
Anyway, it's there.
So what I can then do
is to basically go ahead
and do GCloud ML Engine,
pointing at the core, which
essentially comes from the
repo that I just showed you,
saying, please go ahead
and run this on a TPU
using TensorFlow version
1.8, because that
was the one I tested it on.
And with these many images.
So this is the one thing
that you have to change.
Figure out how many
images you have.
And pre-process it.
Run it.
You have a trained model.
And then once you have
your trained model,
you can deploy it on ML Engine.
You can deploy
anywhere you want.
And then you can just
invoke the model.
It's just a Python program.
And you should basically
get back the classification.
Send in a JPEG file.
So when you're
invoking the program,
you don't need
TensorFlow records.
So just send in a JPEG file.
You get back the classification.
So questions?
So bottom line then, state
of the art image model
pretty much all done.
Right.
So essentially
run a few scripts.
Take your data.
Make sure your data
is in that CSV format.
Right.
Name of the file.
Category.
And follow the code lab,
and you should have it done.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Should you delete all
your TensorFlow data before,
because that takes
up all this space?
You expand on these JPEG images?
LAK LAKSHMANAN:
We don't actually
expand on the JPEG images.
The JPEG images in
the TensorFlow record
remains compressed.
It remains the JPEG bytes data.
The only thing that
we are doing is
we are taking the JPEG bytes
data that's in those files.
And instead of it
reading individual files,
it's going to read
one TF record.
It's going to get 1,000 of
them, along with the label.
Right.
So it's good.
That's essentially
what we've done.
We've basically minimized
the amount of IO hit
that has to happen.
AUDIENCE: Not expanding.
LAK LAKSHMANAN: Yeah.
It's not uncompressing the data.
No.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] so
much faster afterwards?
LAK LAKSHMANAN: Exactly.
Yes.
Absolutely.
As you pointed out, even though
you have to do this conversion,
it is so much faster.
Because you do the
conversion only once.
But you train so
many epochs, right.
Rather than doing the conversion
75,000 times because you're
doing 75,000 now,
whatever, you get
to do the conversion only once.
So pay the penalty once.
And that penalty also, you
can scale it differently.
You can run the Dataflow job on
50 machines, where you may be
training it only on two TPUs.
So instead of you doing
this thing on 16 cores,
you now suddenly did
it on many more cores,
because hey, CPUs are cheap.
So do it on a lot of CPUs.
So let's flip from state
of the art image model.
So you want to train
an image model.
Pretty much take the code.
Run it on your data.
And it's trained.
Right.
So basically the choices
that you have to make
are essentially how big of
an image model do you want?
Do you want Resonant
50, or Resonant 18,
or Resonant 120 something?
Depending on the
number of images,
you can go deeper and deeper.
So that's essentially
the only thing
that you might want to do.
You might want to hyper
parameter tune it.
And that's fine as well.
Right.
All of these models support
hyper parameter tuning.
So you can basically say, don't
just train the model once.
Train it with all these
different parameters,
including the depth
of the Resonant model.
So let's change a little
bit and say, how would we do
state of the art text models?
OK.
Unlike image models, with
text it really matters.
Right.
An image is a consistent format.
Everything is the same.
You're just basically
training an image model.
You're just training
an image model.
With text there are some
differences, some things
that you have to deal with.
So basically when you're
doing text models,
the modern day text
models essentially
consist of four steps.
They do an embedding
where they're basically
taking all of those words and
converting them into numbers,
into vectors.
The second thing they're
doing is that they're now
encoding these using an LSTM.
And then, while you're
training, you're
basically shifting the
attention during that sentence
to basically focus the LSTM
model on a certain length
so that it learns
to basically expect
what's going to happen there.
And then finally, in this
combination of this embedding,
encoding, and then
attending, and then you
have the prediction phase, where
you're basically predicting
the next word of a sequence.
But you're predicting
that in a conditional way.
And then you're playing a
Beam search during prediction
to choose among those
different possibilities.
OK.
So you have to basically
write those models.
And deservedly, these
have this reputation
of being really hard to train
and really hard to get right.
So it's really,
really cool that we
have a library,
Tensor2Tensor which
basically provides this best
of the breed language model.
And luckily enough,
it also runs on a TPU.
But unlike images, it's
not just scripting.
We have to do some work here.
So let's talk about what
kind of work we have to do.
So let's say we want
to basically write
a machine learning model to
complete our lines of poetry.
So given this line, we would
like the model to do this.
Is a model going to do that?
No.
Obviously not, right.
The model is going
to do something.
But the idea is
to basically have
it create plausible next lines.
And how do you train a
machine learning model
to create a plausible
next line of poetry?
What do you train it with?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAK LAKSHMANAN: Real poems.
You train them with real poems.
So what am I going to do?
I'm going to go look
at all of the poems
that I can find, lay my hands
off on Project Gutenberg,
and basically slurp them all in.
And my input is going
to consist of one line.
And my output is going to
consist of the next line.
That's my label.
And I'm going to basically
give that to my model,
and say, this is my input.
This is my output.
Text input.
Text output.
Train.
Fair enough?
So in order to do that, what we
do is that we write a problem.
And the thing is that I
recognize that my input is
text, and my output is text.
So what I have is a text to
text problem in Tensor2Tensor.
So I have a text
to text problem.
And I'm calling mine a poetry
line problem, because I'm
predicting a line of poetry.
And then I basically
specify how many words
I want this model to remember.
Now, I thought I would get
lots and lots of poems.
But it turns out people
don't write that many poems.
So all I ultimately
ended up with was
about 60,000 lines of poetry.
So it wasn't a very big dataset.
So I had to kind of
limit my vocabulary here.
Right.
So I did 2 power of 12 words.
Just learn the most common 4,000
words in this poetry database.
So that's the size
of my vocabulary.
And then I need to write a
generate samples function.
Given the data directory,
it's going to basically yield
a dictionary that consists
of two things, the inputs
and the targets.
In my case, the input
is the previous line.
And the target is
the current line.
Fair enough?
So that's code I write,
basically saying what
my vocabulary is, what
kind of problem is it--
a text to text problem--
and that I want to
read in something.
I want to write out something.
And then I basically said, go
ahead and generate data for me.
So this is, again, very similar
to what I had to do in images.
I don't want my
TPU sitting there,
basically reading 20
line poems everywhere.
I want to basically create
this data in such a way
that my input, output
overhead is minimized.
And so what I'm
doing is that I'm
basically running this
data gen, pointing
at this is the problem.
This is my data directory.
So basically go
ahead and read it,
and write TensorFlow records.
Fair enough?
And the reason it can do
this is because I told it,
given my data files, how do I
create my input and my output
from a machine learning model?
Really when you think about it,
that's all it needs to know.
How do I create my input?
How do I create my output?
And then it basically slurps
through all of the data
that you specified
in this directory,
and creates the
TensorFlow records.
Once you have the
TensorFlow records,
we are ready to train the model.
But then I realized
that, hey, my model
isn't going to be great.
It's not going to
be great because I
don't have enough data.
Remember that first
graph I showed you,
how much data do you need
for a from scratch model?
Right.
The typical Tensor2Tensor
thing, by default,
is setup for English
to German, from all
of speeches ever
given at the European
Parliament or something.
So a humongous,
humongous dataset.
And I'm going to give it
60,000 lines of poetry.
It's not going to be big.
So what I want to do is to
basically make the model small.
So these are my
hyper parameters.
I'm basically saying, just
use two hidden layers.
Just use 128 nodes in them.
And filter them with 512.
And my attention heads.
How many words do I look
at at any point of time?
Look at only four
words at a time.
And do a lot of dropout.
What does dropout do?
AUDIENCE: Shuts
down the neurons.
LAK LAKSHMANAN: Dropout
shuts down the neurons.
Right.
And the basic idea is,
it limits over-fitting.
The smaller your dataset,
the more dropout you need.
So because my
dataset is so small,
I'm going to basically
increase my dropout.
And I'm going to slow
down my learning rate,
because I don't have a
great amount of data.
So use a lower learning rate.
And that's my hyper parameters.
So other kind of small
tuning that I do to my model.
And at this point, I can
just go ahead and train it.
And the model is a
transformer model.
And I have my hyper parameters
set as transformer poetry,
because that's the name
of my Python function.
That returns this
hyper parameter set.
So I'll go ahead and
use that hyper parameter
and run it on ML
Engine with one GPU.
Or run it on ML Engine with
four GPUs, or eight GPUs,
or whatever.
If I wanted to run
this on a TPU--
kind of wasteful, because
this is a small data.
It trains in a few
hours on a GPU.
But if I say, I don't want
it to train in 20 hours.
I want it to train
in 12 minutes,
I would basically flip
that, remove the GPU part,
and add minus,
minus, or use TPU.
And that's pretty much it.
Right.
And what transformer
is going to do
underneath is if
this flag is set,
take this thing that I'm doing,
and give it to TPU rewrite.
That's all it's doing
underneath is basically
calling TPU rewrite with all
of the code that's already
been written.
Fair enough?
AUDIENCE: How many TPUs does
it use if you set that flag?
LAK LAKSHMANAN: You can specify.
You can specify how
many cores you want.
AUDIENCE: Just as a [INAUDIBLE].
LAK LAKSHMANAN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: When you did
the validation data,
did the poems come out right?
LAK LAKSHMANAN: Let's see.
I don't know if
it's still running.
But that is a cool thing.
For a while I had it running.
Poetry.
And let's see.
I think it's called ML Poetry.
Let's see if it's still running.
So that was the blog post.
And there was a link
somewhere in there.
I don't know if I shut it down.
But If it's not--
OK.
So give me a line.
I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: When shall
we three meet again?
LAK LAKSHMANAN: When
shall we meet again?
AUDIENCE: We three meet again.
LAK LAKSHMANAN: We
three meet again.
OK.
So again, it's not going to
give you the exact same poem.
No.
You want it to be
a different poem.
So this is an app engine thing.
So no one's run it for a while.
But it should come back
in a couple of seconds.
Let's see what it does.
A water by a stray
in sweet sole.
[LAUGHTER]
Poetic at least.
Let's do this.
Let's take that line, and make
it do the next line to it.
We ess each a sawing.
Ah.
That is terrible poetry.
OK.
Come on.
Somebody give me another line.
AUDIENCE: The woods are
lovely, dark, and deep.
LAK LAKSHMANAN: The woods
are lovely, dark, and deep.
Ah.
Some Robert Frost
aficionado here.
Oh, error.
[LAUGHTER]
What happened?
Oh.
A yet long not died and
dews on how on the lei.
Oh, that sounds
actually pretty good.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can it look at
a picture and do a poem?
LAK LAKSHMANAN: Can it look
at a picture and do a poem?
Absolutely.
That would be an
image to text model.
And you can train it, as long
as you have enough of a data
set of images and images lines.
AUDIENCE: Have you done it?
LAK LAKSHMANAN: I'm sorry.
Have I done it?
No, I haven't.
Again, it was easy enough for me
to think of Project Gutenberg,
and going and getting lines
of poems and training it.
So as before, this--
now, I don't want to
lose track of the fact.
Yeah, it's a fun thing.
But this notebook is
also available on GitHub.
So you can go look at it.
You can try it out.
try running it.
You can run it on a GPU.
Run it on a TPU.
Right.
And all of the code is there.
So go ahead and
please do try it out.
So last bit.
Custom models.
OK.
So we now know how to
create an image model.
Just take an image model.
Take a text model.
We know where to go find
it and how to run it.
The last bit that I
want to talk about
is how about if you wrote
your own custom model?
And I'm going to assume that
you wrote it using Estimator.
If you wrote it with Keras,
you would basically do a Keras.
After the model you would do
a Keras model to Estimator,
and you will get
an Estimator out.
So it's one function
call on your Keras model.
After you do model.compile, and
then you do model.doestimator,
and you have an estimator.
So the idea is that now you want
to basically run this on a TPU.
So what do you have to do?
You have to enable
that replication.
How do we enable replication?
The cross shard
optimizer business.
Right.
We also want to
avoid host latency.
How do we avoid host latency?
AUDIENCE: Converting to TF3.
LAK LAKSHMANAN:
Converting to TF records.
Put them all in one place.
You want to do static shapes.
Now, that's something we
didn't quite talk about.
We said we had a matrix
multiplication unit.
What does it work with?
It works with matrices
of a certain size.
If you want to go multiply a 3x3
matrix, it's kind of wasteful.
All right.
So what we're going
to do is that we're
going to basically bring in
a huge matrix to multiply.
And that matrix is
a systolic array.
It cannot be this
variable shape.
It has to be a static shape.
So what we'll do is that
normally in TensorFlow
programs, we'll read batch
sizes with a question
mark in the shape.
We won't do that.
In a TPU program we will
have static, fixed shapes.
Normally it's not a problem.
But if you have things like
language models, for example,
you might be padding
each batch differently
based on the longest
sentence in the batch.
That's not going to work.
You have to pad it to the
longest sentence in the corpus.
OK.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: This restriction
because of sharding?
LAK LAKSHMANAN: This restriction
is because of the fact
that the speedup happens
because of the MXU,
the matrix multiplication.
And the matrix multiplication,
it's a systolic array.
It requires a static
shape so that it
can optimize this speed.
OK.
So you would have to do
padding of the tensors.
So how do you do this?
Well, what you do
is you basically
use the TF data API
to read your data.
And when you're doing a TF
data API, during training you
repeat forever so that you
never have any leftover batches.
All of the batches are
of a specific size.
And then you read TF records.
We talked about that, right.
You read TF records.
Don't read anything else.
And you basically go ahead
and do a parallel interleave.
So you basically read
them so that every worker
gets its own copy of the data.
And when you do your
pre-processing, et cetera,
you do them in a parallel batch.
So you call the prefetch.
And then you make sure that
you always have static sizes.
So if you have an evaluation
dataset that is 315,
and you basically want to
make it divisible by eight,
you drop the three
images or whatever.
Right.
So you do that,
and then you make
sure that the first
dimension is your batch size.
So you transpose your
input if necessary.
Right.
And then you basically
make anything
that has a question mark
in the TensorFlow shape,
you actually give
it the actual size.
So this is basically
what this does.
It basically sets the shapes.
Anything that's a partial
unknown, you set the shape.
And then you basically create
a TPU estimator instead
of a regular estimator spec.
Again, I'm running through this.
But we'll try to make
the deck available.
So you'll get that.
And then what you saw
in my Jupyter notebook.
You find the TPU with
the cluster resolver.
And having found the TPU,
then you basically go ahead,
and you train and evaluate the
way you normally do your train
and evaluate.
With this thing,
there's this idea
that there are some functions
that you execute on the TPU.
And there are some
functions that you
execute not on the TPU.
In general, all your input
and output is not on the TPU.
Everything that is on the
TPU is all the matrix math.
So with most machine
learning models,
the model function
is on the TPU.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is there a
profiler so I can see?
LAK LAKSHMANAN: Yes.
There is a TPU profiler.
So when you run it,
it will tell you
what fraction of the functions
that they are running
on the TPU are
optimized for the TPU,
and what percent
aren't optimized.
We try to shoot for about 70%.
It's really hard to get to 100%.
But we try to shoot
for about 70%.
And the more you move all of the
pre-processing, all that stuff
into the input function,
and you leave your model
function pristine, the higher
that fraction is going to get.
And finally, you save the model.
And the cool thing is, I
want to save the model.
It's just a normal model.
And you can serve it either
from a CPU, or from a GPU,
or from a TPU.
OK.
So you can export the model.
When you export the
model, it exports it
both in a TPU serving format,
and in a GPU serving format.
So you can serve
from it either one.
So all of these steps that
I just rushed through,
they're now explained
in that blog post.
And there is a
GitHub repo as well.
So that demonstrates
what that code is.
And with that, I just
want to do a plug.
We have this promotion going on.
We have a bunch of
training courses.
So on Coursera, if you go to
Coursera.org/NEXTExtended--
don't tell anybody
that NEXT is over.
Just go there.
NEXTExtended, and you will
be able to basically get
I think one month free.
OK.
So you can take any of
our Google Cloud courses
for a month for
free with that link.
Cool?
So what courses?
There's a bunch of courses.
You can take any of them
for a month for free.
So that's the link.
Coursera.org/NEXTExtended.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]